foreign
what's up guys
hold up
this should work
smoothly unless I have to pair it again
yeah
there we go
oh I like that sound
that's right
that's right I can't
I'm gonna have to play through the uh
to the TV because you guys can't hear it
what's up stage what's up Sam
strange Bloom keeps getting thicker
we've been descending for a while now
these tunnels are deeper than I thought
what could be down here
princess Hyrule
hey why do I got maxed
[__]
hold up
[Music]
is that the master yes the master sir
come on Zelda
let's go Zelda
something's gonna happen I have too many
hearts and and equipment people have
been falling ill after coming into
contact with the Gloom drifting through
these Caverns
though here it seems almost Misty and
not concentrated enough to harm us
we'll keep going
coming up from beneath Hyrule Castle
I'm playing on um on my monitor
we do not know what rates below so we
need to be ready for anything
but
I know I'll be okay with you link
let's go solve this mystery
[Music]
foreign
look at all that energy your stanima bar
is crazy
top 10 game is it that good order
appreciate the five uh five Super Chat
man
appreciate it
because trust me
it's rough out here man it's rough
all right let's do this
oh
oh yeah
this game does ironically run better
than uh when I played no it's not 60
it's 30. unfortunately
there's no other place for me to play
this
what is she looking at
they slow in the gameplay down man I
can't stand it
hmm
okay
I like how the sword glows so nice
is that the Zone look like they seem
different than us and such large ears
how did the runes from a civilization
and the sky end up being here beneath
the castle
looks like the path ahead of us even
deeper looks continuing
[Music]
you're not hurt are you link
look at these murals
the written histories of the Royal
Family
include stories of a Great War fought
long ago
it was a conflict between Allied tribes
and someone only ever referred to as the
Demon King
because that means skyward Swords before
this game possible dude these murals
depict the same Legend
this is similar to the statues we saw
earlier a zonai
and these figures look like hylians
depiction certainly suggests that the
zonai descended from the heavens
[Music]
see I like this narrative Focus man why
can't more in a typical games do you
said that my ancestors the first of
hyrule's royal family
were born from a union with Gods who had
descended from the heavens
tell a similar story and if they are
accurate then the gods mentioned were
the zonai
they must have forged a relationship
with the hylians of that time working
together to establish
Kingdom of Hyrule
this figure
he seems to be stealing something of
incredible power from the young Kingdom
oh this is interesting this all aligns
with what I've read during my studies
and then this it shows the Demon King
and a fierce battle against him
appreciate that
you guys can still hear the the audio
right you should be able to incredible
luxuries
[Music]
this is the imprisoning war and the
events that led up to it
not free
I'm surprised by the the amount of
narrative in this
you pointed and clicked oh
it looks like the rest of the mirrors
are obscured
[Music]
what's up Andrew
what's up guys what is this place
maybe we'll find
let's keep moving deeper
foreign
you could tell this is definitely a
a 30 frame game
what I like about it if
it doesn't feel like it's dropping like
it's inconsistent
feels like you get used to how the game
plays you'll be fine
what is that
what is this place let's continue but we
must be extremely careful okay
[Music]
oh
is that getting it off
is that is that Ganondorf Gandalf not
Gandalf is that cannondorf
looks like those things from
leave with the Zelda to mess things up
man
of course told you
[Music]
was that the sword that seals the
darkness
where you can shatter so easily against
my power cannot save you from me
who carries that fragile sword a link
replaced his faith in you
and that was all you could do
but do you
know our names
oh
give me some like Wind Waker at the end
of five
oh so he's the one that makes everything
go yeah
thank you
I wish I could just
it's 20 frames per second yeah
they need a new a new engine
new system too
[Music]
oh what is that
that was the hand that
that was holding him up
And So It Begins they should have had
like someone say that in the background
and so
it begins
what is going on
it's like a new power what's his arm
why is he always getting naked man
how'd he lose all of his
his clothes
link finally you wake
how long you been asleep
I've heard a great deal about you from
Zelda who are you talking about
your wounds were severe
I am relieved to see you escape death
your arm however was beyond saving it I
had to replace it lest the injury
endanger you further how do you just
replace an arm
someone explained that to me
someone explained to me how you just
replace an arm
the master sword all messed up too
I can still rock with it
[Music]
it's kind of crazy because if you think
about it
this thing is different like if this
thing's like it can't be Darkness
like this thing can't be Darkness
because if it was Darkness the master
sword would have did more damage to it
this thing's like not Darkness or light
it's something else
foreign
[Music]
look at this the new Zelda game look at
the master sword sexy man
I'm not really hungry man I'm not I'm
just not completely there
I gotta save my money
came with a millennium
can we please relax folks can we relax
before we start saying game with a
little Millennium yes I'm playing golf
[Music]
laughs
Where'd I go
oh
gotta go outside
I'm naked though
how you just gonna jump off like that
[Music]
but how do you just jump off a mountain
like that
well like a a high cliff like that like
what round did he think he was gonna
live if he jumped off
floating it's it's like he tries to try
to commit
suicide
[Music]
yeah because that's realistic
look at that draw
yeah okay
oh my God
I just wish it would have gave a little
bit more like if he had a reason why he
could survive
things like that
oh this game
it's running real sussy
the most the Masters will run low on
energy
you think
let's just pick up this tree branch
we're gonna beat him with a tree branch
let's pick up this tree branch
yeah
it's definitely making me a little
nauseous I'm not gonna lie
[Music]
link
I have waited for you
princess Zeta left something for you and
MacKay
you left me a switch
why couldn't she have left me some
clothes
I didn't pay for this okay IOP pay for
this
[Music]
I gotta play a good amount of it tonight
for to give a good thing when it comes
to IOP though I want to be able to like
what I I'm not going to stream like this
whole game obviously but I got to make
sure I stream a good amount uh I play a
good amount of it today
I have now passed it on to you my
records indicate that Princess Zelda is
waiting at the location marked on its
map
he messaged my message has been
delivered
[Music]
we stand in the garden of town
the Temple of Time is visible from here
it was used in the distant past majores
of the Kingdom were held there
but no more
now it's a lovely place no one visits
King held the lion at launch
ah stop that man stop that
that everyone everyone's very real on
IOP
I appreciate the nines were the nice
words
who wants it next
I got a tree branch
we just we're just hoping that there's
water below us
see that one's a little bit different
because you could actually see the water
if you look down
but that other one there's no way he saw
water at the bottom
that man jumped with the
what's the thought process that he
wasn't gonna hit it
it's some big geese
[Music]
a sky shroom
is there any different property from a
sky stream in a regular shroom
what's the difference
is a chest there but I don't think you
can make it there yet
oh it runs so bad I mean it's it's
definitely not the worst 30 frame games
I've ever played but
it definitely could be better
come on come on
ow
oh oh
we gotta look for something else
there's got to be something around here
I will find something else to hit this
stupid thing with
[Music]
where is it
he's got a branch on fire I wonder if
it's like
got to get destroyed
oh my God
[Music]
I appreciate it
I love the attic sure I love doing it
with dirt
Sky shroom
nope
nope nope
I just need to like find something to
hit this dude
yeah I I try to be I'm a streamer a
podcast or a content creator
I really should like focus on one of
them and grow them
I think I'm a better content creator
than streamer
now everybody grinding
I appreciate the kind words but be nice
oh here's a stick
there's another stick right here
okay
take this guy's room
what you doing
I appreciate it man
I know I put in work I know I do
a wooden stick
so now we're into a wood instead
we got to get some weapons because that
Master Sword probably ain't gonna be
ready for a little bit
yeah now Nintendo definitely gets a pass
but here's the thing people get Nintendo
passes yeah I play breath of the law
people give Nintendo passes because no
like
what are you gonna do in the end like
they they won't let you play their game
anywhere else
so it's either you don't play it
it's either you deal with their shitty
performance or you don't play it
oh
my wooden stick broke
what is this
a long stick
I got a long way before I get the master
sword back
at least they let you have it at the
start I like how they did this most the
time wandering I don't like how like
they set up sequels but this is a decent
sequel I suppose we're not talking to
the tutorial dude
[Music]
yeah we're gonna eat that
oh it's making me talk to him
I have noticed before that you were
unfamiliar to me my apologies
among my tastes explain anything that
Visions May acquire knowledge of you may
have questions about this place please
rest assured that a construct can answer
them
go
I gotta play probably at least five six
hours a night I gotta play a decent
amount of this
we're gonna have like a big thing
talking about
I gotta make sure that I have a good
amount of this game played before IOP
so I'll play a little bit tomorrow I do
got to make a video from my personal
Channel tomorrow
you know I'm going through a breakup too
so that's made like my content fell a
little bit
like my relationship get it get it get
it
oh God
forget my life
come on
[Music]
oh
a rusty sword hold up
[Music]
I appreciate it man
um I don't really like going live on my
channel I'm trying to do better at
keeping stuff segregated a little bit
um most the time though like if you want
to support me just support IOP and just
watch my videos you know you could just
through a super chat in here because uh
you know IOP did pay for this copy so
you know I if you guys want to you know
give a little bit you know I can I can
justify
me getting free games
look at this arm it reminds me of the
Devil May Cry on with sufficient power
I'm sorry
I did not intend to startle you
who is this Messiah that spoke to you
earlier
that arm originally happened to me I
feel you I feel you I appreciate it man
I gotta PayPal man you want to go above
and beyond I gotta pay power for you
that insistent
but I appreciate you if you guys just
sit here and chill with me man I
appreciate you guys coming through
fortunately
I no longer have a
physical
in any case that arm should allow you to
open the store
seems to have lost the power to do so
how do you
you might be able to restore it
but you would need to enter a place
filled with sacred he looks like he's
made of that sacred light just go over
there and take it from him of course
why not visit the shrines on this island
[Music]
I love how everyone is so helpful in
this game
the shrines yes I'm sure they are the
key
[Music]
so we're in the in the process of
because I wasn't going to go to like
the the thing in LA because E3 wasn't
there uh but it looks like I I might be
going
how do I get over there
I guess we'll just have to go over there
and try
okay
tomorrow we have a tick talker on uh on
Facebook on uh IOP I really like this
dude guys like show up with this dude
this dude a night he's a good dude and
you know Tick Tock screwing over there
their content create well Tick Tock
isn't the American government is
uh so go over there and uh you know uh
show up tomorrow because this dude's a
good dude he's a good he's a good
content creator I think I think you guys
would like his content
how do I get over there
I wonder if I can jump down and grab one
of the bottom shafts
I'm gonna need some Stanwood to get up
there
the sense of adventure
definitely helps this game I'm not gonna
lie
because it feels like you actually can
go anywhere you want like you're normal
at the time they'll like make you get
another little uh item here so you can
get up here I do feel like that's what
breath of the law does really well is it
gives you the
the the feeling that the game is open
you can do whatever you want
yeah
I wonder if I can just climb up to the
top now
[Music]
I'll be right back guys someone
following for me
[Music]
all right I'm back
foreign
feels kind of big not gonna lie
so these are the shrines I didn't like
these in in a breath of the Wild
oh
[Music]
Ultra hand grab and move objects rotate
them and stick them to other objects
freely and attached to other objects but
that you'd be able to build a great
number of things really anything you can
imagine use our turn and receive a
blessing from this shrine
foreign
feeling like breath is a wild
[Music]
hold up
all right I gotta un stick it hold up
okay
all right
so let's stick that down
all right so I think you're supposed to
hold up
come here
thank you
hold up
all right so yeah I'm doing it wrong
I need that
there's a ladder right there
come on
there we go
all right so now we got to rotate it
attach
that'll work
thank you
okay
I know that's probably a way easier way
of doing it
but we're doing that
yeah it is getting
oh guys I had a hard time with that
what is this
[Music]
okay hold up
can I attach it to this
if I think I'm going to want to rotate
it
foreign
I doubt this is gonna work
no it doesn't
no let's get over here
back over here I ain't done with you
okay there's a jump button
yeah I keep forgetting there's a jump
button
this ain't God of War
Nintendo values jumping
what do they say these are um
these are gifts
or blessings
I think they use the word blessings
[Music]
May the light of blessing Grant you the
street you seek
I love that they just shut them in
whatever device that's in
probably won't stream long today guys uh
you know
not really feeling it 100 percent
trying to get myself through the day man
breaks up breakups suck
you never lose track of them
all right all right let's do this
place a pin
all right so that's pretty much exactly
like breath of the Wild
[Music]
all right so let's attach that
foreign
here we go
nice little mechanics
I don't know why I came over here but
oh they want you to do it again
some reason pardon me
things I should just take the one I
already made
and add it to this one
okay hold up hold up
I just gotta get over there
foreign
come on
how do I bring it close to me
there we go
good
that'll work
I dropped one in like the abyss
all about just learning how to do stuff
man
[Music]
all these damn cool crazy seeds I hated
these things
[Music]
that really come over here for one of
those lame things
I really did didn't I
probably like one of those things that
really teach you how to play
I thought I could just jump anywhere
yeah yeah
I wonder if I can grab this thing
yep dead
wonder how far they make me go
they make me rebuild that
oh hell no
you got to be kidding me
can you cut a tree down
oh my God
dude
I think I might just take this in my
room guys and play it
no offense to you guys but
you know I'm going through a rough time
and I think I'd rather
play by myself uh
but I'm not
release
I got no arrows
oh never mind I got five arrows
uh I wouldn't go that far yet yeah I am
enjoying it
well before I get off let's try to make
something crazy
hold up
right there
no I want that
what's funny is uh Nintendo
oh I can't because of that
what's up
thank you
all right let's see if we can get to the
uh
see if there's people on the side
is it this
what's stopping me
oh I'm gonna fall
appreciate the con Wars Jay
it's rough but I'll get through it
oh no no
I
no I thought I was detaching it for the
one before
wow
no no
come back here
you ain't going nowhere
not without me
oh this is mad smart I feel mad
uncomfortable
can I catch this on fire
does it catch on fire
we got wood
and these big ones will make those small
ones yeah
acorn
[Music]
foreign
what are we doing with this
[Music]
what if you can kill yourself by
accident
yep
looks like you can take some form of
damage
all right you guys I appreciate everyone
coming out I stream for about an hour
I'm just not in the mindset to be
streaming I appreciate it for coming
through though I'll be on IOP tomorrow
we'll be talking more about Legend of
Zelda uh so far so good really fun time
I'm really enjoying it
uh
you guys have a good day peace